it's wonderful to welcome you here this
day then if you would please remove your
caps and join me in invoking the
presence of our Lord and Savior let us
pray
send out your light and your truth let
them lead us let them bring us to your
holy hill into your dwelling come on
your father and you we live and move and
have our being preserve us this day by
your gracious power eternal son by you
we share the divine likeness strengthen
us this day to live as becomes this gift
sanctifying spirit through you we have
adoption as sons and daughters in the
heavenly household comfort us this day
with the warmth of your embrace Holy
Trinity everlasting God who was and who
is and who is to come
remind us this day of your past
faithfulness that we may have bright
hope for tomorrow how faithful you have
been O Lord to bring us to this day
you have surrounded us with so many on
whose shoulders we not stand family
friends and pastors teachers coaches and
those who always saw the best in us you
have not left us alone and we thank you
and here we are on the frontier of an
undiscovered country of opportunity
challenged growth and change
we are excited and terrified all at once
expectant and uncertain joyful for new
beginnings and sorrowful as we say
goodbye to what we've known until now
things change but you remain the same be
our anchor and stay this day this week
this year confident that you hear us and
that you care we lay before you our
hopes and our dreams our fears and
anxieties our pasts and our futures and
short we offer you our very selves souls
and bodies and all our strength and
weakness and we ask your grace to make
them a fragrant and living sacrifice
pleasing to you and for your glory
through him who gave His life that we
might live your son our Savior Jesus
Christ amen please join me in the pledge
of allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
please be seated
again good afternoon
a special thanks to our Prelude ensemble
and our bagpiper
and a hearty welcome to the students and
parents of the graduating class of 2021
does that sound a little strange to
refer to you as a graduating class
already well as the good Reverend Rick
said in effect get ready I am dr. David
Whalen College provost on the platform
with me today our president Larry Arne
rising seniors Kathryn shy and Dustin
platon who will speak momentarily in
fact Katherine is she will join us also
momentarily she will be singing in the
choir dr. Dan Copeland EDA faculty dr.
Chris Van Orman Dean of Natural Sciences
dr. Steven Smith Dean of the humanities
and dr. Paul Marino Dean of the social
sciences we also have dr. RJ pissed reto
the Graduate Dean and of course Reverend
Adam Rick the Hillsdale College chaplain
so I've just invited you to sit may I
ask you now to rise with the Hillsdale
College Chamber Choir as we sing our
alma mater you are invited to join in in
the second verse the conductor is our
very own professor James a Holloman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's eternal meaning on the on the
sword my gear those woven waters with my
solemn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yes yes yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Jim and thank you members of
the choir well now hear from our two
senior students Katherine shy who just
joined the platform party is a senior
with a 3.5 nein grade point average
she's majoring in French and minoring in
journalism and she intends to pursue a
career in journalism at Hillsdale
Katherine takes part in the upper
workshop in the journalism program she
performs with the concert choir and the
chamber ensemble and she serves on the
newspaper staff as well she also works
as a student residence director in her
dormitory she previously completed a
communications internship with Concordia
welfare and education katie is the
oldest of three children her family
lives in Clarkston Michigan where her
father is a design release engineer for
General Motors and her mother is a
worship coordinator for the Clarkston
United Methodist Church Dustin
platon is a senior English major with a
3.8 eighth grade point average his
future plans include graduate school
teaching and nonprofit work at Hillsdale
he takes part in the collegiate Scholars
Program and serves as both a resident
advisor in the Galloway dormitory and a
goal leader for an exam or ghen ization
called a few good men
he also tutors at the campus Writing
Center and plays on an intramural
basketball team and an intramural
volleyball team dustin is the third of
nine children
his older brother Zachary is a
post-secondary student his younger
sister Cecilia also attends Hillsdale
his family lives in Whitesboro Texas his
father is retired and his mother is a
home educator Katie and Dustin
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Whelan for introducing me
Thank You Dean Philip miss Dell Dean
Pete and chief for inviting me to speak
today I would thank the choir too but
that would seem rather self-serving but
thank you guys for your support mostly
though I thank our new freshmen who have
unwittingly entrusted their very first
Hillsdale College lecture to me this is
like this lecture is also the last you
can enjoy it without taking notes so
you're welcome I don't want to puff all
you new arisal arrivals up on day one
but I do have to acknowledge an annoying
fact that often irritates us
upperclassmen you class of 2021 have
raised the bar so high that had I
applied last year I probably would have
had to endure a second SAT boot camp to
get into this place so based on your
impressive track records I'm guessing
that earlier today I'll use smarty pants
fancy-schmancy newbies marched right
into your dorm room claimed the bottom
bunk and exchanged horrified glances
with your parents and silent agreement
that oh yeah your roommates a weirdo I'm
sure you embodied confidence as you
slept the perfect amount of knickknacks
and decor up 10,000,000 stairs and I bet
you strutted right down to this very
lawn and plopped into a chair ready to
officially get this show on the road
yeah that is not how this day went for
me three years ago I will never forget
how I felt when my parents dropped me
off at my dorm I was nervous to the
point of nausea admittedly if my
queasiness probably had less to do with
my utter terror starting college and a
lot more to do with the odor of my
family's van which stank of stale french
fries and melted crayons but once my dad
threw our trash can on wheels into park
I knew I had just arrived at my next
phase of life and I felt doomed because
I had no idea what was coming this thing
I had been researching writing essays
about taking standardized tests for it
was finally here college as a whole
package experience existed on the other
side of the van sliding doors and just
because their handle stopped working
five years ago did not mean that I could
hide from this next stage forever
the imminent unknown terrified me
because I had no idea what to expect I
had no plan of how I would make friends
where I would go to church when I would
eat my meals what classes I would take
past this semester or what major I would
sign my life away to and beyond the
logistics of life I also had no clue as
to how I would ever excel at such a
challenging school now I'm going to tell
you something I wouldn't have believed
if someone had said it to me at my
freshman convocation my lack of plan and
expectations put me in the best possible
position I could have been in back then
and that's the best thought you can be
in right now - you have no idea what
your path will look like here at
Hillsdale no amount of planning thinking
whirring palm reading 8-ball shaking or
fortune cookie eating will enlighten you
so instead of trying to make your future
happen just dig right in engage and
invest now I'm not saying you shouldn't
plan it all trust me my academic career
that first year could have used a little
more thinking ahead but don't feel like
you need to have everything figured out
right this moment or even by the end of
the year forget about trying to invent a
game plan that will let you graduate
with honors in three years so you can
apply to journalism school a year early
marry the man of your dreams two years
later when it Pulitzer by 30 then retire
four days after you turn 62 kick back in
a rocker to bounce 11 grandchildren on
your knee til Saint Peter called you
home a professor once told me that
military strategist say no plan survives
first contact with the enemy any of my
early yearnings to be a writer shriveled
up and died when I saw the grade dr.
Jackson had marked on my very first
paper four great books my underdeveloped
unimpressive unimpressive and now
this of Ovid's metamorphoses certainly
put the C while C - in college so this
year invest in a lot take your classes
seriously do the reading ask smart
questions visit office hours write
intelligent essays and when you figure
out that you do not yet right
intelligent essays spend some time
figuring out how to do so engage in dorm
life have fun at campus events and maybe
even venture off our little slice of
paradise once in a while I didn't even
have a driver's license freshman year
but rough draft and handmade are just
down the road and they make great little
getaways join a few clubs make some
commitments you might have to back out
of next year get a job try something you
might hate something you've never done
before go to a football game go to an
orchestra concert if you truly have no
idea how to spend your time come find me
and ask to help out writing our student
newspaper the collegian soon enough
you'll be begging to reclaim your nights
of leisurely Netflix watching but don't
do these things to build your resume to
impress your high achieving Hall mates
or just to have something to talk about
when you call home do these things
because this is what we do at Hillsdale
we read and we think and we talk we talk
a lot you can't fit any of that onto a
spreadsheet or Google Calendar or even a
five-year plan you'll never pencil in
have life-altering encounter with
capital T truth at 2:00 p.m.
in philosophy 101 but that's the kind of
thing that makes this crazy school worth
it and that's what you'll do here if you
really dig into these next four years
you know one of the first things you'll
learn in western heritage which is Hill
sales cooler version of Western Civ one
of the first things you'll learn is that
you know nothing I'm pretty sure it's a
devious joke the professor's decided to
play on every freshman they make you
recognize upfront what they're about to
prove to you for the entire semester
that you know nothing but in the
Republic which surely you'll read part
of this year Plato puts it like this
I am the wisest man alive for I know one
thing and that is that I know nothing I
demonstrated this idea
quite beautifully in my early papers it
was very clear that I knew nothing sorry
dr. gamble but if you engage here you
might just end up knowing a little
something you'll know lots about
whatever subject you decide to study and
that will look very nice to your future
employers
at least that's what I hear from my
graduated friends who now have big kid
jobs you'll know some other things too
though things that will tell you how to
live the good life and that's because
Hillsdale will teach you about
conviction Hillsdale will humble you
challenge you and lighten you renew you
and it will do all that because within
this school are excellent people from
the administration to your professors to
your peers I can't tell you exactly what
your Hillsdale experience will look like
but I hope you open yourself up to what
it will offer you a thorough education
in life as in letters I'd like to leave
you with something
Augustine said in his confessions I
think it might give you a good idea of
the blessing this place can be a
god-given gift you'll never be able to
plan on or bring about through worry he
writes when I was with my friends my
mind was occupied with our talking and
laughing exchanging kindnesses reading
good books together now joking now being
serious disagreeing without animosity as
one might disagree with one's own self
teaching and learning from one another
sorely missing those who were gone and
welcoming Joel with joy those who came
these and suchlike signs coming from
hearts that loved one another through
mouth and tongue and a thousand gracious
gestures were the kindling of a fire
that melted our minds together and made
the many of us one I would like to
joyfully welcome you class of 2021 if
you need anything I live on the first
floor of mock the building right behind
me and I'm always happy to help thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon thank you to Katie thank
you to dr. Whelan and Dean Phillip for
giving me the rather terrifying honor of
addressing you this afternoon at every
admissions event I have ever attended
dr. Arnn made a point to warn me and you
that this place is very hard he's proud
that the difficulty of this place is
built into the school's motto strength
rejoices in the challenge well I'd like
to follow up on dr. Aaron's warnings in
this your first post admissions event I
went to show you at least in my opinion
one aspect of this difficulty and why
you should rejoice that you came here to
face it
coming into my freshman year I did not
understand what the challenge of the
motto meant I thought it meant the
challenge to keep up with grades in
difficult classes I thought it meant the
challenge to stand out socially to have
the right opinions the right friends the
right interests I thought I meant the
challenge to create the perfect college
experience I wanted to take the right
classes with the right professors get
noticed by the right people and the
right campus job and summer internship
it took me until Thanksgiving of my
freshman year to realize how wrong I was
after that holiday I rode back to campus
in the backseat of a car with some
Hillsdale people I'd never met they were
just the sort to intimidate me high GPAs
campus leaders noticed by professors so
here I am self-conscious me in the
backseat of this car dreading the next 7
hours that I would have to spend
awkwardly not embarrassing myself in
front of them I did not have to worry
they spent the next seven hours talking
about their difficulties and
their accomplishments they further
surprised me by not measuring themselves
according to the standards that I
thought were important such as grades
popularity or responsibilities they'd
rather expressed concern that they were
exhausting themselves on the wrong
things they changed my thinking they
changed my life by the time the car ride
ended I understood that fulfillment
would not come even if I measured up to
my old standards of success this made
failure according to those standards no
longer shameful so I grabbed a guy from
my dorm that acknowledged to him who I
really was
with all my fears and insecurities and
failures he affirmed that I had been
viewing this place and its challenges
incorrectly the correct challenge as he
saw it is to become like the people in
that car a good friend you become one by
being real and devoting yourself fully
to the best things let's unpack that
reality and devotion just a bit being
real means not pretending that your GPA
your social skills or your resume define
you none of that will fulfill you they
are not the reason you were here you're
not here to get a good GPA a couple of
years ago after the average GPA on
campus was announced as a stunning 3.3 a
beloved professor marched into class in
a huff he delivered words that haunt me
he told us that we work too hard that
there is more to college than grades you
are also not here to build your resume
with campus leadership take a few good
men a volunteer program that does manual
labor and service projects for the needy
in the community the best project I ever
helped with did not further the hubris
of any great leader we accomplished
nothing more than raking the leaves and
easing the mind of a man with
Alzheimer's take the dorms the RA that
impacted me most never felt important
enough to fix my problems he just
brought me coffee when I was studying
and dragged me to a volleyball game when
I was studying too much now
I'm not saying you should abandon
excellence and leadership far from it
please study serve lead but understand
that any so-called accomplishment should
only reflect your devotion to something
great
Hillsdale makes it a point to let you
know that one of those great things is
truth you're here to pursue it
our professors work hard to ensure you
also love the pursuit of it I happen to
be an English major which means that I
also love the simple pleasure of reading
but it turns out devoting yourself to
truth or even just to reading is not
easy to do my first semester junior year
I got ambitious academically I wanted to
take two 300 level English classes and
two 400 level classes outside my major
no big deal I thought it's only 12
credits but I couldn't do it
even after I dropped one heart class and
picked up an easier one even then my
semester was hard I often had to choose
between studying Augustine's Confessions
or hearing the hilarious sobering
confessions of my dorm friends over Taco
Bell at 2:00 a.m. I had to choose
between spending my time reading
people's stories or creating stories
with my friends while out raking leaves
and painting siding for the needy in the
community it seemed as if academics and
people conflicted that frustrated me if
Hillsdale challenge is to devote
yourself to the best things isn't
friendship a good thing - of course it
is
I would like to assert that we cannot
pursue truth without also pursuing
friendship
friendship is also a best thing one
reason that classes and friendships seem
to conflict however is that we cannot
learn friendship from our classes we
must learn it from others and practice
it during our time here this should give
us cause to rejoice so many people here
want to walk with you teach you learn
with you and from you remember the story
I began with the car ride with two
strangers
it was strangers from this place who
modeled one aspect of friendship being
real the guy I could return to and
confide in it took just one guy that
cared about me to model another aspect
of friendship devotion he did so by
listening to me that one evening letting
me know that I was more important than
anything else he had going on and then
he stuck by me for the next three years
to make me a friend that could share in
both study and laughter class of 2020
one read choice that strangers and
friends await you here they give you
strength they give you joy devoting
yourself to both them and truth is your
challenge in this I believe Hillsdale is
special every student on every college
campus faces questions about who they
are and where they're going
Hillsdale gives you answers in the form
of both truth and friends worthy of your
devotion every now and then someone
reminds me to stop take it in
acknowledge how incredible it is that we
are here here we study amazing things we
do so alongside people pursuing the same
things we are truth and friendship
which are the best things welcome to
Hill sale I rejoice that you are here
among strangers and friends I pray you
will rejoice as well thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Dustin and Catherine a few
housekeeping details after this
convocation we ask students to join
their adviser groups immediately to the
rear of this assembly if you turn around
and look behind you you see an army of
vaguely Irish looking people wearing
green green t-shirts they're back
sitting on the hill
those are your advisor groups parents
are invited to dinner in the Searle
Center dining room also direct not not
directly but but approximately behind
you if you can imagine walking through
the building you see right there and
walking through the construction site
into the next building assuming you
didn't get arrested walking through the
construction site that next building
then would be the sural Center so that's
for parents Larry P Arne is the 12th
president of Hillsdale College he
received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD in
government from the Claremont Graduate
School he served as director of research
for Sir Martin Gilbert the official
biographer of Winston Churchill from
1985 to 2000 he served as president of
the Claremont Institute for the Study of
statesmanship and political philosophy
in 1996 he was the founding chairman of
the California Civil Rights initiative
proposition 209 which was passed by
California voters and prohibited racial
preferences in state hiring contracting
and admissions dr. Arnn is on the board
of directors of the Heritage Foundation
the Henry Salvatori Center of Claremont
McKenna College and the Claremont
Institute he served on the US Army War
College Board of Visitors for two years
for which he earned the Department of
the army is outstanding civilian Service
Medal he is a member of the American
Political Science Association the Mont
Pelerin Pelerin society the
International Churchill society and the
pelant repeat roundtable published
widely in national newspapers magazines
and periodicals on issues of Public
Policy history and political theory dr.
Arnn is the author of
liberty and learning the evolution of
American education and the founders key
the divine and natural connection
between the Declaration and the
Constitution and what we risk by losing
it dr. Arne has recently published
Churchill's
trial Winston Churchill in the salvation
of free government blackburn is a
professor of politics in history here at
Hillsdale he teaches courses on
Aristotle Winston Churchill and on the
American Constitution he and his wife
Penelope have four children Henry
Katie Alice and Tony please join me in
welcoming dr. Larry Arne thank you
father Rick Provost Whelan professor
Holloman and the choir I see you had
some ringers in there who've already
graduated great to see them doing it I'm
going to keep Jonah in town now so she
could be singing forever Thank You
Katherine and Dustin beautiful and funny
which is really good but did you catch
the joke in Dustin's introduction his
future career plans might include
nonprofit work teaching ministry or
construction management that means that
boys got no idea what he's going to do
it it also means he can do all that your
kid parents will get a job when they get
out of here unless they're lazy dogs in
which case they'll never graduate from
Hillsdale College
welcome back faculty it was a pleasure
to see you all lined up there I was I
was more glad to see you today than I
was last May when we all said goodbye to
each other which is decided the job
still ok for all of us at least me
welcome freshmen would you stand up
please
thank you thank you and welcome parents
of the freshmen would you stand up
please have any mothers cried yet would
you hold up your hand yeah okay it's
gonna get worse before it gets better
Hillsdale College is a bad news first
kind of place there are three hundred
and ninety four of these freshmen that's
twenty four over the goal and that means
many of you can be spared see that was
that Destin yeah we're starting out hard
here today you come from the largest
applicant pool we've ever had and you
have the average entering standardized
the highest we've ever had by a smidgen
over last year so on the average you're
really smart which is fully compatible
with profound ignorance I just want to
tell you the significance of this
ceremony and if what we're about to do
and make a deal especially with the
parents we're going to make a deal with
you freshmen tomorrow when we talk about
the honor code what it means and then
you're going to sign it these deals are
profound and this ceremony expresses
them I want you to understand as you see
the significance of these things that
none of us has any choice about these
things these are the things that we need
and if we wish to live as well as we can
we have to have these things in the
ceremony we had
session we have robes the robes display
ranks there's singing there's a prayer
is a salute to the protector of our
freedom which by the way is what lets us
do this what we do here so long as we
can keep it those things parade and from
in front of us as they have in colleges
since there began to be colleges and
think how long ago that was Plato had an
academy almost 2500 years ago
Bologna and Oxford Waylon and I both
spent time in Oxford so we love to point
out that it's about 45 years of older
than Cambridge they're both over 900
years old and all of them were like this
and everything in between
by the way until just lately is like
this and just lately there's been a
change but what is it to be like this
the young seeking to do something that
has very little in a direct way to what
they're going to do for a living come
and study with people who are older and
wiser and they all learn together that
is the phenomenon I've had people you
know we have I forget now I think we
have a 1.5 million online students and
then you know and it's growing faster
last year than the year before lord
knows how many they'll be right but
there's about 1500 of us here and
there's about a hundred and sixty
faculty sitting right there the most
important of the professional people
here by the way and that ratio and the
expense and trouble of all of this you
freshmen you're about to get acquainted
with the trouble and then when the
trouble really comes upon you then
you're gonna call mom and dad and
they're gonna get acquainted with the
trouble then then why why that well it
comes out we have come here to think in
exactly that way that is a synonym for
talking because you know animals show
every sign of thinking they just don't
talk
and we do and that thing that goes on in
our soul that makes the kind of thinking
we can do that goes on between us when
we converse and that means we were made
to think together and especially if you
think about things that are ultimate
things things that will last your whole
life and you're 18 and you don't know
any better than that boy back there what
you're going to do with your life or
what's going to happen to you right but
what you know is there are some things
you need to know because everyone needs
to know them if they are to live a rich
and happy and significant life and we
are here to do that that's what's hard
it's joyful you'll love it but also hard
get your boots on places here are scarce
there for the willing and the able and
those are both very high qualifications
before we get to heaven because we're
gonna study our way up toward heaven
that's the thing that happens here if
you just think you want to be an
excellent person surely you want that of
course you want that you can't help but
want it well you'll find out that as you
improve yourself you're reaching upwards
not down and so before we get to heaven
the road to heaven involves being good
and I'm sorry to inform you that you're
gonna have to learn to define that word
and if you can do it right now I'll give
you five bucks
especially if you'll give me ten if you
can't you have to be morally good that
means what just courageous and moderate
truthful all of those things right you
have to behave yourself here you'll find
that we don't govern the place mostly by
rules there are some rules but they're
not important because for example if
somebody ever gets in enough trouble to
get into my office which happens once or
twice every other year or something like
that then I always I can never remember
what rule they violated I always say you
remember where you are only 1 since 7 to
17 years I think we've had the honor
code for 14 years only ones have I ever
got out of students honor code and asked
him to verify his signature but I said
you know and I just said did you sign
that document and he just you know you
big old football player boy and he just
got really tiny and I said what did you
do again and of course he was deeply
ashamed I didn't have to do anything to
him he kept begging me to punish him I
said I'm not here to punish you I'm here
to be your friend which by the way you
can learn about in class ignorant boy
the minute he said that because that was
a really great tuck but the minute he
said that when I booked just darted a
glance at each other I'm down there I'll
bet you were all doing the same thing so
you have to be good and you promise to
be and I just want you to understand the
significance of the honor code because
what it means is we govern this place by
goals and goals are intrusive that means
you have agreed to them that means you
can't violate the code without getting
caught because you catch yourself duh
and that means we're not really very
concerned about your behavior
it'll be fine except when it's not and
it won't take long to fix it
that boy by the way when I read I made
him verify his signature on his honor
code I'm a reference for him now he came
back to my office twice to beg me to
punish him and I said you just go put
this right and he said how do I do that
and I said I don't know I didn't make
that mess there's a kind of bad thing he
did and I said you know I'm angry enough
at you because you spoke ill to one of
my staff members a lady and you did
something to a girl that she didn't like
wasn't that bad but it was bad I said
you know if you don't put this right I'm
gonna erase this time from your life and
you'll never be able to come back here
I'll ban you for 40 years till you're
dead so you know I was really working
him over but I didn't have to do any of
that why he longs to be good there'll be
these obstacles you're young your body
is stronger everyday pleasures mean more
to you with every passing day you are
made that way the pleasures indicate
something to you that's worth having
almost always although of course you
want too much of it or in the wrong time
and way
you have to learn to listen to those but
they cannot govern you and then
intellectually it's gonna be hard
because I promise you're going to
discover that you can't say a sentence
about the things you know the most about
without some learning person asking you
what those words mean and you'll find
that you don't know and it's like
starting over again and it's hard and
then everybody's made A's what's the
average grade point average here three
nine three nine five or something like
that forget that that's over right I
think last year the average freshman
grade point average was 2.9 and so
you'll cry and say I've always made A's
and we'll say okay sure this is college
now that's different right and you and
you'll think I'm going to despair that's
when you need assertiveness and courage
and you must have those you must work on
those and everyone here will help you
with that no one out there and I won't
tell you who they are today but there's
about eight guys down there
that are girls that are just ochres
about grading I mean they just it's just
it's they could be prosecuted
and yet their classes fill up right
everybody down there is really bad and
there's a few of them that are just
worse you know and and they care deeply
and they will help you right
you must not despair it is a failure of
courage to do that if you start looking
like somebody from the scene of The
Walking Dead which we will all look to
look like in the first week of December
right then if you start doing that too
early get help
we'll help you but then there's this
other thing it's the opposite side and
you mustn't do this either
and remember what I say you mustn't you
mustn't for two reasons because you've
agreed not to or you will by tomorrow
night or else you'd be going home right
or more than that I say we all need this
you need this to be what you can be to
be like them who are on their way
farther than you right now farther than
they were when they came here so one
thing we do because we do learn a lot of
really cool stuff and then we go back
home at Christmastime and we meet our
friends from high school and we find out
that they're not reading and all the
complicated stuff in science and the
humanities that we're reading and we'll
feel a very superior and then I'm a
public figure you know and I go around
talking about the college all the time
and I brag about it and you know I brag
about you about them I mean every word
of that I couldn't work here if I didn't
mean it on the other hand that's for
them out there right because here we did
not come here to congratulate ourselves
because the example that we seek to
follow is the most excellent even divine
and we're never going to get there are
we going to work with intensity and
never be satisfied
because if we do wonders will unfold and
happiness's will come to us that we
could not otherwise have but if for a
moment we get smug I met two boys you
all get invited over to our house for
senior dinner it's a big institution
around here right and by then you'll be
like a really big cheese and you'll come
over and give me advice about how to run
the college it'll be the first advice
I've ever had and I should introduce my
wife penny who's at least as nice as
your own mom you should stand up yeah
[Applause]
see she's gonna give you dinner more
than once right
but last spring I had these four smug
boys and I'm gonna be talking about
those boys for the next decade I am
gonna make their name a byword
everywhere they go because they just
thought they'd figured it all out right
and they were you know they did a thing
we didn't like very much wasn't quite
bad enough for me to destroy them but I
didn't even harm them but you know I
wanted to and why because they'll grow
up and they'll be fine right they're
awesome kids but you have to learn that
you must never be satisfied with
yourself so you see what the two virtues
you need our humility assertion courage
restraint how do you develop those
practice takes time it is hard to sit
for hours at a time and concentrate
especially when you're nagged that it's
too much and you can never really get it
you'll need your courage but then when
you get it and you start putting things
together and you start articulating
things that you didn't know and you
didn't begin to get a glimpse that these
things are beautiful oh
you you'll have this thing he doesn't
described it you'll have this thing
that'll happen in your and you'll sit
back and you'll say that was satisfying
to learn for its own sake and it will
never stop you will encounter a pleasure
most self-sufficient and abiding and
when you get that you must not be cocky
about it you must work harder and get it
more and then you'll be able to give it
to others for the rest of your life
and then you can save the world which is
what we do here
I don't have to make any pledges that
we're not going to have the craziness
here that is prevailing now I said you
know since Plato's Academy and Bologna
and Oxford there's continuity but lately
that's mostly disrupted in most places
you know if you think that you've come
here because you want to do whatever you
want to do well we've got twenty four
hundred and ninety-nine competitors and
they'll all let you do that
you've just chosen the wrong one can't
have happened by chance
well what are they what are they doing
right
they tell these kids that there isn't
anything valuable to know or they tell
them that their consciousness which is a
term of art and historicism is formed by
their gender and their race and their
class and all these background things
right and then they demonstrate and they
take over the president's office well we
have no threat of that here I only bring
it up as a positive thing because that's
going on in the world and it hasn't for
most of the history of this College
which is almost 175 years old we can
learn from that you see what are the
arguments they're actually making and
they do constitute an overwhelming and
stark alternative to what we do here and
so we can look at that and say what is
the argument that's actually there what
are they doing like you know the way it
looks to me of course I'm an old man and
you know so very learn it and all that I
always you know first time I saw a bunch
of marching at a place where I got a lot
of my education I was sitting with my
wife and we watched in the news and they
were taking over a building that I know
and they were demanding changes to the
curriculum and they're 19 years old and
I said you know somebody needs to stop
those kids and ask them to define the
word curriculum because they've never
completed one right how would they know
it's hard for us to do that well my
point then is we are an alternative that
is very different and we get to go
through the hard
job of making a case for that under
pressure when we defy the examples if
you got the crazy idea that you were
going to take over one of the college
buildings I'll just tell you that that's
a simple problem the college property
belongs to the college who does the
college belong to all nonprofits and
colleges are a singularly important and
dignified form of that along with
churches the most all nonprofits belong
to their beneficiaries this college
doesn't belong to you and it didn't
belong to me and it doesn't belong to
the board it belongs to the
beneficiaries and you freshmen are about
to become our immediate beneficiaries
and for four years but the beneficiaries
also include all those who come after
you the board has its authority because
it acts for them the faculty has its
authority because it possesses the
knowledge to pass on the things that the
college was founded to pursue which are
for and what you have to learn what they
are because you have to serve them you
see I'm saying this isn't ours we are
here to protect and preserve it and pass
it on we will keep our humility about
that and then we can argue all we want
to and the only speech code around here
has just two parts civil because Dustin
said it we are here to become friends we
are supposed to love each other and the
other is academic that means high
quality seriously thought out carefully
formulated we have to learn to do that
all the time
finally parents you too are part of our
partnership the immediate blessing for
you that we do not take any money from
the government is we can send you your
child's grades and we are going to do
that sometimes they don't like it and I
have a device I've used I've only had to
use it once there was a
girl favorite girl monster school
teacher doubt raylene co cynic and she
could protested about that she said
doctor I worked all summer and all time
here and paid for my own college why
would you send it to my parents so I had
the envelope redress to the parents of
the very mature and independent
raylene ku cynic she thinks that's funny
now tisha didn't at the time
if you come prepare this weekend which
you must hundreds come it's crazy it's
not nowhere else like it we will all sit
we all think it's kind of cheesy but
also inspiring and we will sit at tables
with little nametags and people ring
bells you get ten minutes with every one
of these if your kids got got this and I
do that - we all do and that means
you're in the mix you're part of this
place and you're about to take a pledge
to say so now there's bad news that
comes from this - because you have to
look at this in the old-fashioned way in
the very unlikely event that we have a
dispute with your child you are on our
side for sure immediately and without
any question you can find out later
who's wrong and then you can switch
sides if you want to you won't because
why because if you got a complaint we'll
listen to it and you know we're not bad
at this it's what we do for a living we
will include you we are all on the same
side and any time we have a real dispute
going on among us we try to settle that
right away because that's not what
colleges do what they do is argue about
things they all love
Frischmann you have three commands in
regard to your parents call your mom dad
if you're not home sick pretend to be
when you go home at Thanksgiving or
Christmas don't slip and say when you're
coming back here that you're coming back
home it will make your mother cry the
rest is up to you you parents are going
to take a pledge and you'll see around
here we mean things like that
I took a pledge to hold a job I hold
it's my station in life and this pledge
is dominating of me I can't get away
from it there are times when I want to
you'll find that yours is like that too
but of course you already took it
you had these kids and then a great and
also a bad thing is going to happen your
kid's gonna go off up the hill and
you're not gonna see him anymore I'm
sorry about that but not really we'll
have dinner
I'll tell jokes about how cruel we're
gonna be to your children and then you
can cry on the way home I said to the
Provost of course a friend of mine as we
were all processing in here because we
get to stand up there and watch the
faculty come in and it's fun you know
we're all excited today this is a cool
day and I said to him you know it's fun
also it's Holi isn't it this is one of
the most serious things that human
beings can do we're starting today may
God guide bless and protect us in the
work welcome
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Arnn we now approach the
end of the ceremony and so I would ask
all students and their parents to stand
as we dedicate ourselves to the high
purposes before us dissident is an
important transition in our lives and it
is proper that we should acknowledge and
declare our mutual commitment inside
your program you will find the Hillsdale
College matriculation ceremony pledge as
representative of the faculty I will
read the first part and then the
preamble we ask the freshman to respond
by reading in unison the second part
titled matriculates I'm going to ask
Katie and Dunstan to join me at the
podium and to speak with the freshman in
their portion of the pledge
founded in gratitude for the blessings
of civil and religious liberty Hillsdale
College is a seat of higher learning
here on these grounds generations have
given themselves to the pursuit of truth
the love of wisdom and the grace of
intelligent piety here in these halls
generations have come to perpetuate the
high calling of learning and the noble
love of the good in gratitude still and
in concert with these generations
together we pledge ourselves anew to
this great purpose Hillsdale College in
its zeal for learning and its embrace of
academic integrity and honorable conduct
commits to students all the talents
knowledge and intelligence with which it
is graced educating by precept and
example it is dedicated to the liberal
education of students in whom it trusts
that learning will rise to wisdom and
that virtue will be blessed with
strength matriculants commit ourselves
to diligent study and patient reflection
having come to learn we are proud to do
so with integrity and we'll conduct
ourselves with exemplary honor as
sacrifices past and present made
possible our education we to become
stewards of this College for the
generations yet to come we pledged
ourselves to the per student of truth
the love of the good and the cultivation
of beauty for the sake of our minds and
hearts and for Anna noble society by
doing we embrace the high calling of
liberal education this pledge bespeaks
our unity in a great purpose
intellectual and moral wisdom blessed by
God is the foundation of a good and
humane life and the necessary condition
of enduring Liberty may God bless us now
and always as we
our minds refine our passions and seek
the good parents please turn to your
sons and daughters now officially
Hillsdale College students and give them
your blessing
please remain standing for a spoken--
benediction followed by a song
benediction Reverend Rick made the God
of peace who brought from the dead our
Lord Jesus Christ the great Shepherd of
the Sheep by the blood of the eternal
covenant equip you with everything good
that you may do his will working in us
that which is pleasing in his sight and
now may the grace of our Lord Jesus
Christ the love of God and the
Fellowship of the Holy Spirit be with us
all evermore
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]